pause actually do this computer just the
power he hadn't uh or the organizer
hadn't put in the power cord
and The Duda came back very he was
actually losing that game but he came
back very strong yeah he's he's very
good at kind of freestyling Duda and
just being in the moment thinking on the
Fly
um if you give him a random position
just jump in fresh he'll be able to
navigate the complications well and it's
the same in chess it's like if you just
get thrown in
five minutes on the clock no time to
prepare he's uh I think that favors Duda
lamajarov again just he needs to be
inspired he needs everything to be
perfect to be fully focused and
not ideal no far from my deal and uh
okay three minutes have been lost on his
clock he will get that time back I'm
pretty sure
and uh we will sort out these issues it
looks like dudo as well a moment ago was
maybe talking to an Arbiter or just
waiting to get an update
yeah it'll be worth it it'll be worth
the wait looks like he's typing so it's
uh probably not fixed yet
we haven't seen a lot of technical
issues this season on the tour
no we didn't have the drama that we had
apart from this game between Duda and
Neiman I mean I remember on season one
we had this huge drama with level
neuronian like the power had gone out oh
in Yerevan and he was just uh banking on
the power on his laptop on his laptop
surviving and it was a big Race Against
Time Yeah would he finish the game
that's true oh that was robotic the
stress yeah
you know those are power cut as well in
Miami if I remember correctly it wasn't
just the
um just not just the wire another day
there was a power cut which affected all
the players in I mean it was unavoidable
um it affected the whole region but
yeah the place they used to this I
remember in Gibraltar one year there was
a power cut and players were playing by
candlelight in the basement where it was
like pitch black yeah there's some great
pictures literally just candles and but
you can barely see the boys but they
kept going yeah that happened to me it
happened twice actually in two different
years it happened to me that I was down
there playing it was pitch dark and we
had these like candles these lights
happening I mean it was very creative by
the organizers to and the Arbiters to
think of this solution yeah so I
appreciated that sounded kind of cozy
and there is a message now from the head
Arbiter that mandirov has had an issue
but he will start and he has started and
he has received all his time back so
here we go this is the must win game for
him any other result means Duda wins aim
chess rapid yeah and these two they've
both been so good the entire tournament
it's coming down all on this game now
and it's the English opening so it
started as a ready white tonight coming
out but it's we call it the English
opening because those two seaporns white
Seaborn black Seaborn they're out and
it's symmetrical and uh okay both sides
for being Kettering their Bishops on
their long diagonals dude just going for
a slower approach but this one does mean
that there'll be maximum tension very
rarely do pieces get traded off here
because there's no confrontation in the
center both sides flexible the variety
of plans at their disposal but uh what
do you think of this opening Choice from
White's point of view yeah it's very
cage using it like you say it kind of
keeps all the pieces on the board it's
going to be a very slow game
um I think it's okay to begin with I
mean he must have gone into this game
with a certain strategy in mind and you
have to remember that of course mama
jarov is in a must-win situation and
he's not really going to appreciate
those situations where it's all very
tense he's my best stylist to go forth
and Conquer and it puts his Knight to
the edge of the board that wasn't the
most popular move according to my
database but it has been played several
times yep still a well-known plan in
general for black
um that Black Knight on the edge of the
board doesn't look great but it will
re-centralize itself soon Mama Jara
first castling
data copying and yeah the reason I'm
slightly surprised is this one is
maximum tension it's all about nerves
yes my major likes to be a bit more
direct but Duda with white normally top
players nowadays the strategy is to be
direct and just
Hoover up all the pieces and go for that
draw if it's required okay Duda pushing
Upon This Might preface a further Pawn
Advance on this left side for white uh
manager of copies yeah
this is the whole point of The Rook wall
swing over and now white is gearing up
to expand on the left side of the board
obviously you can't do that just oh you
can do it actually what am I talking
about there is a knight sitting there at
the edge of the board come on come on
Duda push forward with a B Pawn to sport
yeah so the idea is if blacks Bishop in
front of his King ever moves then white
dark Square Bishop will go and capture
that Black Knight on the edge of the
board so Black's Knight he does play
your movie of anchor so this is a trade
essentially an offer of an exchange
Black's dark Square Bishop can go and
capture White Knight over there on C3
but then White's Bishop will go and
capture black snake on the edge of the
board so a bit of a weird unusual way of
trading pieces normally the piece is
kind of trade for off for each other but
uh not in this scenario instead manager
I think this is a wise choice just
centralizes his piece
and doodle protects the Knight that was
attacked and yeah we will see almost
symmetry complete symmetry actually in
the position if Duda trades off a set of
Pawns now which it would be very logical
but uh symmetry doesn't in this case
mean a draw because they're still all
the pieces on the board and only it's
two sets of Pawns have been exchanged
and okay Mama jar of pushing in the
center he loves pushing gaining space in
the middle of the board because once you
push in the middle it's easier to Dart
off an attack on either side later
I I really like what Mama giraffe is
doing you know he's threatening to push
that deeper and one square forward and
just I try to disrupt White's Pawn
structure
so uh this is going to be unpleasant for
Duda to handle yeah would you block
things up in the middle now do they you
can kind of push white spawn to block
this black pawn that's just moved no it
wouldn't I wouldn't do that because
it swings and roundabouts yes you
prevent Black's plan but at the same
time you concede a very important C4
Square so I would say no don't do that
you've got to fight this fire with some
water and just maybe move a night out of
the way yeah makes sense and
compared to the last game at least clock
times it's a complete reversal now Duda
is down to three minutes mama jarov's up
at nearly four and a half in the last
game that Mama jar have lost it was uh
him burning time early that cost him and
now the shoes on the other foot White's
Queen meanwhile moving also quite
sensible
um just connecting the white Rooks now
the white Rooks can bring themselves to
better squares
and uh yeah I mean clock time often I
found this as well in my own Blitz
practice with white there's this
psychological burden that you have to
prove an advantage or you have to create
something and that costs time on the
clock so even though Duda only wants a
draw or only needs a draw somehow that's
maybe in his head
and he's overthinking he's not being
quick up to this point no and uh shark
is playing very solidly it is not making
any committal moves whatsoever I fully
expected him to be maximalist and take
as much space with the pawns but he's
like no let's first develop the pieces
he's learned the lessons from the last
game and instead put the queen out
connect the Rooks and then fight for the
battle in fight in the battle of open
lines yeah
maximum tension right now dude again one
and a half minutes down on the clock
that's a huge desparity on time and
I'm getting worried this is not a Duda
type of position either necessarily or
he's a universal player but he's his
instincts aren't in these blocked
positions where it's hard to come across
a plan his instinct is again to play on
the front foot go forward he snaps his
Rook forward
mysterious move that Rook is on a loose
square and uh manjarov he doesn't
actually worry about necessarily playing
the most accurate move he's just playing
quickly he's putting pressure on the
clock and that's a valid strategy due to
shaking his head already
is he back in that tilt and uh White's
Knight stopping back that night was in
the way of whites Rooks makes some sense
but not a good square that white knight
it still needs two or three moves to get
to a better circuit Chuck chases it back
and this has been uh dude a sneaky plan
all along it was to maneuver the night
to B3 to work from where it can jump to
C5 and you can see Duda is satisfied
with this plan and I like the calmness
of Shaq he's like no okay fine I'm just
gonna Retreat my Bishop
so white has a weakness black also has a
weakness the two b-pawns one white one
black they're both isolated now White
Queen was eyeing up a pawn okay a couple
of quick moves there but look at this
black is the first into the white half
and this is the first time a black piece
has jumped into the white half of the
board and that's a phenomenal Outpost
yeah look at that Black Knight on the C4
Square anchored by two pawns protected
can never be removed yeah I have to say
I feel that uh Duda is the one
struggling big time here because Shaq
has control of the A-line he has the
better Bishops and of course the better
Knight and Duda now in defensive mode
maybe this The Strain and the stress of
having to just draw this game is
starting to take its toil toll yeah
I mean well there is a plan at least for
white uh what black has done with his
Knight in the white half white wants to
do to Black in his half so he wants to
copy and white tonight is going in
between the two black knights next move
um yeah it's it's going to be really
hard to evaluate whose Knights are
better it's just so blocked in the
middle of the board and uh the one thing
Shaq can't allow is a whole bunch of
exchanges so tension between the Rooks
the longer it goes on
it's gonna be unclear who that favor is
okay he just moves his Queen getting
ready for the other black Rook to go to
the a file to join uh that tension over
there
and uh yeah dude it still feels like
he's fine but the clock time worries me
like jumping in there it is will he get
rid of it yes absolutely wow okay this
comes with pros and cons White's best
pieces removed but black is giving up
control over all the dark squares very
risky strategy I'm expecting white to
take this bishop back normally we say
towards the center so why it's B Pawn
should capture but this is a stronger
way because white dark Square Bishop
look at it on the bottom of the board
behind the White Queen as a nice
diagonal now if it gets to C3 it's going
to cut across and uh look at the black
king side
oh this one I mean it's so tense it's
not clear who has the advantage on the
board on the clock it's still navajara
off yeah
yeah and he'd keep up the pace
Duda he is in the lead in The Blitz tie
breaks it is a Friday night it's been
looking like he's smacking on some
chocolates enjoying himself today yeah
I'm Christopher
but in this game is he enjoying this the
bar is now going over to his side yeah
again we talked about the bishop her a
few times this tournament and I do think
White's Bishops have potential despite
the fact it's blocked and closed right
now I'm looking at that white dark
squared bishop and I'm thinking that's
the potential winner that's the MVP as
they say most valuable piece
and uh Black's Queen just defending some
pawns right now and uh Duda well what a
turnaround you know he's really
maneuvered his pieces beautifully and
how calm is Duda he's got one minute on
his clock crucial match tournament
decider and he's just sipping his uh
sipping his drink a moment ago and
Retreats the White Queen I love that
Retreat I mean it's just so
sophisticated it gets ready just to
perhaps look at the left side of the
board and at the same time this queen is
perfectly placed in case he wants to get
aggressive and start pushing some Pawns
in the middle and wow
chakra he's lost patience he has now
struck he's ruined his perfect Pawn
structure and this is it I mean but this
is very very weakening yeah it's very
weakening Black's Pawns in the middle of
the board look nice
but they are targets especially for
white to light squared Bishop uh clear
targets there I guess he just had to
fight on Dart squares this is his idea
as well he's going active he's starting
to set threats uh the white truck is
attacked by a Black's Bishop and yeah
black had to put one Pawn on a dark
Square because potentially he was weak
on that color complex The Rook moves and
the bishop offers an exchange this is
clever if you remove white slight
squared Bishop which has happened oh
there's a blunder oh I was going to say
strategically black was doing well but
this Knight drops off Black's Pawn is
overworked if black captures this Rook
the White Queen goes and captures the
black Rook white has won a piece
oh no and he resigns it's over a young
Christoph Duda wins aim chess rapid
after a massive tournament he won the
preliminaries he knocked out